if you've been watching me for a while
and you know that I have done a lot of
things in my past that I hate YouTube
star Shane Dawson is facing backlash
over some resurfaced videos and it seems
no one is more outraged than Jada
Pinkett Smith and her son Jayden Smith
here's what went down on Friday Shane
posted a 20 minute apology video titled
taking accountability to his YouTube
channel
the 31 year olds internet personality
spoke about his past use of blackface
using the n-word joking about pedophilia
talking about murder fantasies and more
this video is coming from a place of
just wanting to own up to my wanting to
own up to everything I've done on the
internet that has hurt people but Jada
and her 21 year old son aren't here for
Shane's apology after one of his videos
that resurfaced showed Shane making a
lude hand gesture towards a poster of a
then preteen Willow Smith on Saturday
they both took to Twitter to weigh in
Jada
tweeting quote - Shane Dawson I'm done
with the excuses Jayden tweeted a series
of red-faced cursing emojis writing I'm
screaming at the top of my lungs and
then addressed
Shane directly writing Shane Dawson I am
disgusted by you
you sexualizing an 11 year old girl who
happens to be my sister is the furthest
thing from funny and not okay in the
slightest bit I swear on my life I am
NOT somebody who would ever talk about a
child like in seriousness I would never
talk about a child in any way that was
inappropriate Shane did not directly
address that video in his apology and he
hasn't publicly responded to the Smiths
but he did say this that is disgusting
that is gross it's not something I would
ever do it is something I did for shock
value or because I thought it was funny
or like oh my God my child molester
character or whatever it's all gross and
I promise that is not real that is not
nice the youtuber also discussed his
past use of blackface
something Jaden described on Twitter as
not okay
racism that I put onto the internet as a
adult not a child
that person was filled with sadness
filled with anger about their own issues
I don't know how to even fully apologize
because it almost it seems like
something that is irredeemable or I
don't know the right word but it's
something that I shouldn't even be able
to get out of I should lose everything
for that